Yes !
that's right!
Roberto!
Ricardo!
Supernatural fans, welcome!
the San Diego comic con 2016
Rich : what a year  last season was, Robert!
Rob : what a season!
Rich : turns out, you're God !
you go to bed, a writer. You wake up, God
must be nice
it is kinda nice, actually
it's good stuff. Good stuff everybody
wow, well and more fun in store
season 12!
on the way
Rob : Are you ready ?
let's meet some of the folks!
let's do it! let's dive right in, shall we ?
you know, our first panelist, he's so respected by the SPN writers that they even named one of the show most beloved character after him
Please welcome : demon n°5!
Oh no! Bob Singer!
Bob Singer, everybody
there he is !
Bob Singer, here he comes!
best seat in the house
right next to where the comedy happens
Rich : big congratulations go out to our next panelist. He's finally made it to the top of the letter, Robby
he is the showrunner and head writer of SPN, this is his 1st season. We're a little worried, maybe it's going to his head though, because, we've caught into the great line that when he makes notes on a script instead of just telling the writers to their face
he has a tendency of throwing the script on the ground, leap on his desk and scream : you've got Dabbed, bitches!"
we'll have to find out if that's true. Ladies and gentlemen : Andrew Dabb!!
Andrew Dabb, here he comes!
It's Andrew Dabb
That is Andrew Dabb's theme song.
Welcome Andrew!
Our next, the next guy here : he's the man who's unwaring devotion to winterhead gear, even in the scorches summer months
has lead the entire beanie industry to collectively respond, really ??
Mr Jared Padalecki!!!
Put on the hat! Put on the hat !
Yeah!
And the beanie sells, spike!
Rich : Next, up. A man who's career was launched. You may not know this. With his pivotal role on the soap opera: the bow legged and the beautiful.
Jensen Ackles, everybody!!
Rob: next to the stage : a man who's thankful corckiness is only offset by his grounded oddness
Mr Misha Collins!
And that is not it!
Our next guest,
is a sinister overlord who's relashing making lives hell for all living creatures and on tv he plays Crowley.
Nobody know better how to ruin a moment more than this guy
On stage : Mark A Sheppard !!!
Ladies and gentlemen : Supernatural!
Rob : Alright, let's opening it up to the questions.
Rich : Robby, first question.
Rob : Bob and Andrew, we can all agree that season 11 was pretty epic. You had the darkness, and God. That was pretty huge.
And now, the darkness is gone. So, where do you go from there. I mean, how do  you get bigger than God ?
Bob : Oh, you don't get bigger than God.
Rob : Misha, what about ? So, you've been roughly quiet
Rob : what about,you know
Rob : At the end of last season, Lucifer was finally exorcised from your body. Uh, the lady of Letter casts you away
Rob : where does the season12 find you ?
Rich : dude, he's hitting on your mom !
Rob : you know what? , earlier i ran into an old friend who wanted to ask a question.
really ?
Rob : I said he could
Rich : well, whoever could it be, Rob ?
Hamster : Hello!!!
Hello, you crazy peoples!!!
how the hell are you ?
Rob : we're good, what's going on here ?
not mucho, hey bobby singer good to see you.
Rob : what do you dressed as ?
oh yeah, you like it this?
you like my new accessory ?
guess who i am ?
Rob : uh, a pitbull ?
nope!
Rob : uh, a rapid sensation pitbull ?
that doesn't make any sense!
Rob : lead singer of judas priest
close but no cigar
Rob : my pastor ?
no!!
who ??
I'm Mark Sheppard, from episode 11.15 "beyond the mat"
Rob : that's right
the one where he becomes Misha's bitch
hey look!  i could make it this joke
me and Mark are bros
we're thick as thieves
so Mark, a quick question ?
the licking of the floor bit ?
licking. Of. The. Floor
the licking of the floor bit
when you're licked the floor
don't make fun of my accent !
Mark : kill me now, please!
here's a quick question, the licking of the floor? Improv' or did you make it up on the spot ?
this is what i  go through, day in, day out
Mark, you should be glad it was floor licking. I have a hand in pitching that story and i've had it been nipple clamps
but you know what ? i've got dabbed!
Rob : oh, you've got dabbed, uh ?
i was on board
Rob : okay, well, you know what ?
Rob : i'm gonna sit you down
don't do it! i don't want to fell over. Oh, that's nice
Thank you, Rob!
you have soft hands like girl
Rob : In all seriousness, Mark
Mark : really, you're gonna follow that with a question
Mark : Okay, Rob how you're doing ?
Rob : would you prefer it'd come from the hamster ?
Rob : how about you ? we were talking about family, and what about your family ?
Mark : oh, God!
Rob : Yes?
Mark : that's been a boone for you these days, doesn't it ?
Rob : oh, fantastic!
Rob: best years of my life!